Speaker 1: David, if covid really was created
in a lab. What would be the repercussions? Well,
the the I assume that you mean created in a lab by
China. Obviously, if the if the virus was created
in a lab by, you know, Eritrea, the consequences
would be very different than China. The focus has
been on China. I think with the lab leak stuff,
there's a few different parameters and ways that
that could shake out No. One, if it was literally
created in a lab as a bioweapon and deliberately
released. First of all, it's really stupid because
of how many people died in China. And it also,
in a sense, is a failed bioweapon because the
death rate is comparatively low. If if you really
wanted to do damage and do bioterror, you would
probably develop something that had more than,
you know, like the point seven percent death rate
that covid has. But that's sort of like an aside,
it would have been a really stupid thing anyway,
because if those who believe it was done as a
bioweapon believe it was done to attack the U.S.,
it mostly killed people outside the United States.
It didn't even really cripple economies. I mean,
some countries handled it better than others, but
the economic recovery recovery is going relatively
well. So if that's the case, it was really dumb
and poorly executed, but it would have significant
foreign policy impacts if we learned that this was
a bioweapon deliberately released by China.
I'm not saying war, but it would be certainly
economic war. I believe that that's the least
likely scenario when you look at conspiracies.
The next scenario would be that
it was being studied in a lab
and it accidentally was released. Someone
scratched themselves and then it went out into the
public. If that's the case, I think there
are going to be economic sanctions. I think
it's going to be taken very seriously. I
think there will be consequences, but it's
not going to be of the scale that those who are
clamoring for the it was a bioweapon conspiracy
are sort of pointing to. And then, you know,
if if it was the most likely scenario to me
still is it emerged naturally in China. It may
have been studied in a lab, but the spread did
not originate at that lab. And China pretty
clearly covered it up early. We covered the story,
I believe it was in December of twenty nineteen
of one of the doctors who was saying, hey, this
is going on, this is going on. And police came to
his house and said, don't talk about this anymore.
And China understated the number of cases
in China, understated the number of deaths.
I don't know what the consequences should be
in that case. But you're then talking about.
A diplomatic issue that is far different
than the other extreme, which is this was
a created bioweapon deliberately released, as
you can tell, I tend to think that the reality
comes in sort of those latter examples. As I've
always said before, it should all be looked into.
There is no investigation or analysis that should
not be done. I'm for all of the investigations,
but I think we should be careful not to say that
something is likely until we really know for
sure. And right now, we can't say any of these
leaks are likely. If you have a different view,
let me know. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Sign up at join Kim Dotcom.